[Music]
look what I become
loud so I don't you know okay well uh
listen we're back at it podcast we
haven't done one for a minute this week
because we were in uh
Romania Bucharest yeah we were in
Romania hanging out and uh it's
interesting because Vinnie you were a
celebrity there he dressed up as a
Dracula people taking pictures with you
it's pretty wild it wasn't like some guy
really thought because and how what are
the odds that these tourists just got
back from Transylvania and they were
like uh my wife yeah you were the second
biggest celebrity in Romania behind
another individual so you might have
been the first and and you know
obviously we got a lot of story to go
through and at the beginning we're going
to give you the Tate update uh and just
for everybody because I've been
bombarded swamped with messages about
what's going to be happening here so uh
we spent
um I don't know we have around 12 hours
of footage of content
there will be a behind the scenes
because that behind the scenes clip
alone will be very interesting for you
to see
uh they were very transparent which was
kind of like hey you know take the
camera around you know we we got footage
from a lot of different places
uh we spent seven hours talking to
Andrew and we spent about an hour and a
half talking to Tristan individually the
topics and issues that was discussed was
very deep from BBC to Romania to the
arrest to uh uh what it was like to be
in jail the experience in jail the
dungeon uh uh what things they learned
while they were in their uh moments of
not having access to your phone for 92
days how that messes with you personal
life kids
um of Finance what did they do did they
take everything is there money there do
they have any money left did they take
this did they take that anyways we
talked about everything now while we did
the interview this is one thing
everybody needs to know by the way if
you're watching this
if you want to be one of the first to
get the update on this text award Tate
to
310-340-1132 once again text award Tate
Robert if you can put this in the chat
as well text the word Tate to
310-340-1132 or I'll give you another
thing to do as well Kai if you can send
a link to Rob to put in the description
for people that are not in America
internationally to be the first to get
the email as well Rob uh please text Kai
to text you the proper link and let's
put that below folks you'll see it as
you're coming in and Rob will put in the
chat as well so a lot of conversations
legal was there there are publicists
were there everybody fluent from all
over the place for this meeting and the
interview that goes live I believe it's
5 hours and 20 minutes of content of
which
45 minutes will have to be cut because
it's legal issues about Romania and
their indictment and that'll be live uh
post their indictment which could be any
time now in the next week or two so
there will be what we're working on
right now is for it to come out and be
released the interview number one
I think it's going to be four hours and
40 minutes something like that 4 hours
and 30 minutes and then the other 45
minutes 44 minutes will be released post
indictment so there's going to be two
parts to it and then Tristan's interview
will also be released uh uh here very
soon as well it's epic if you enjoyed
the first one this was probably I don't
want to say 10 times Wilder because even
the intro I don't know if you guys saw
the intro yesterday I did I saw a shout
out to the team for what they're doing
yeah everybody Eric Eric you know Kelly
crew Brandon with the research these
guys really were busting their tails
editing I think they went without any
sleep trying to get it this time and
their crew Tate screw was very
hospitable you know where they were with
us can I give us a shout out yeah Tate
said you guys are the most prepared for
any interview he's ever done then the
research that knows I don't know if we
were more prepared than Lucy Williamson
from bees I don't want to give us that
kind of credit I think we're second best
to Lucy she's the goal yeah and she was
prepared with agenda that completely
yeah fell she was ready killed she just
didn't know it and Pat just just to say
something off of what you said for for
people like I never met him I've seen
the videos obviously and I've never met
him but from start to finish be honest
the hospitality the the sincere genuine
like do you want a coffee uh dude it was
like being in the Middle Eastern
person's house great personality like
bend over backwards to making us feel
did you feel like you were at home I
mean it was the same way last time
though but it was a great experience
this time being in the house when you
pull up to the security security waiting
outside the place it was the driver
knowing who they were and asking around
in the city what they thought of the
tapes you just have to watch the
interview to see all of this combined
and it starts off we give three gifts at
the beginning which you will crack up
and we give two or three unique gifts at
the end which you won't crack up you
will tear up the gifts at the end
because it's going to be sentimental and
meaningful to them but I think it's a
conversation that people need to hear
you're gonna I can tell you one I think
folks when you see this
BBC is going to hate this interview let
me say that one more time they're going
to hate this interview and that may be
an understatement on what happened so uh
but at the same time I think it needed
to be this way people need to hear the
story from them to kind of see where
they're at and then we're gonna see what
the Court's gonna do whether they're
going to get charged they're not still
tilt today it's still allegedly a lot of
people are trying to come after them a
recent story came out with another girl
named Evie
that claimed they did something 10 years
ago we talked about that as well uh
anyways if you're following the Tate
Story You're Not only not going to want
to miss this one I remember the first
one was five hours people like who the
hell is going to watch a five hour thing
and the most common consensus I got
wherever I went and what whatever DMS
and emails and messages that came in I
sat there expect them to just watch the
first 30 minutes I ended up finishing
the whole thing on one sit down and
you're going to see a lot of people
going to be doing that so stay tuned for
that it's going to be epic can I add to
this yeah if we're going to talk about
this yeah I wrote down three things that
I took from this in in general
um the big overdrop that I would say is
I would argue that Tate whether you love
them you hate them appreciate them
disrespect whatever I would argue that
he is inarguably the greatest
Communicator living today the the the
the the ability to understand what he's
talking about but also relate to
Everyday People is fascinating and we
actually had that conversation about I
said you see you have all these belts on
your wall about being a four-time
kickbox Champion I said I would argue
that your linguistic skills and your
Wordsmith uh ability is better than your
kickboxing ability goes I wouldn't deny
that but here's the three biggest
takeaways and you touched on number one
I would say the hospitality was actually
genuinely impressive from
Tristan Andrew his team the ladies
everyone there uh very impressive with
that absolute gentleman absolute
gentleman even when the cameras were off
so this is you can't fake this this is
not a facade number two which I totally
appreciate and I've looked into this was
the adaptability he referenced Darwin he
said it's not the biggest or the
strongest the most intelligent that
survives it's the people who are the
most adaptable or the animals are most
adaptable he talked about being in a
yacht one week being on a private jet
and then being in a jail cell and he's
like I'm totally comfortable with this
adaptability is absolutely amazing and
then ironically the reverse the
adaptability are your values and
principles that he is locked in on
certain things that he believes and they
are unwavering which is very impressive
to me and that he takes full
accountability for everything that
happened and speaking of values of
principles the work ethic the stoicism
the Brotherhood the the finances the
mental Wellness the not believing in
depression uh just being an absolute top
G we had a great time I'm excited for
people to see it and uh thank you
Peabody for everything yeah it was a
great experience so stay tuned guys when
it comes out again text award Tate to
310-340-1132 or put the link below as
well Rob did you put it below for folks
to get the email as well yeah Kai's
working on it right now one question for
you what are the chances that you change
your diet to eating once a day no only
time can coffee
and cigars that's it that's all to 15
cups of coffee and three cigars a day
and only eat once a day yeah you know
what would happen if I had one cup of
coffee I mean it's just later on
honestly if I had 12 to 15 cups of
coffee
you wouldn't work here you would you
you'd be a very different environment
the only person that does more coffee
and cigars a day is the new proud papa
Mario Aguilar Mario shout out to him
Mario baby here Gabriel Baby G Maximo
Aguilar what a name of that guy man yeah
that's it that's a powerful name right
there okay all right sounds good again
text a word take to three one zero three
four zero one one three two uh uh as
we're going through this uh uh we got a
lot of stories to cover here with you
number one the indictment with Trump the
new one that came out there's uh
indicted on seven charges we'll cover
that YouTube Reckless YouTube I don't
know if you guys heard it or not
recently they no longer give strikes for
videos and people that fight the
election in 2020. so they're no longer
taking those videos then which was kind
of weird but you should hear what the
Biden campaign had to say about
YouTube's new guidelines California
governor Newsome announced uh proposes
28th Amendment to the Constitution to
combat gun violence uh uh Cuba to host
secret Chinese spy based focusing on us
and that's not like a
conspiracy websites saying that that
article is written by Wall Street
Journal folks Cuba to host secret
Chinese spy base focusing on U.S RFK did
a Twitter space with musk 300 000 people
there I believe he's making some of the
best points best arguments we'll cover
that as well Chris Licht CNN CEO fired
we did the podcast saying these guys are
probably gonna fire this guy and he's
actually doing good for the shareholders
we'll cover that the real reasons why
Chris slick got fired there's an article
behind that Tucker Crossing did his
first and a second and he took an
indirect shot at Obama's personal life
in 2008 and a lot of people on Twitter
are claiming that Tucker kind of told
him that part of the LGBT you know what
I'm saying so maybe we'll cover that a
little bit and Fox News tell Tucker
Carlson he violated his contract with
new Twitter show Sam Altman fires back
at Elon Musk criticism on open eyes
saying I like the dude but that he's
totally wrong about this stuff again
we'll see what Tom has to say about that
half the world's biggest companies are
downsizing office space I'm did
hibernate working that's an Insider
story commercial real estate crash still
Lumen over the US economy behind ryzen
unemployment job market is really strong
but at the same time jobless claims jump
more than expected to the highest level
since 2021 Butler experienced another
week of sales decline drop another 24
from a year ago
then there's a couple stories companies
that Embrace social issues are starting
to have second thoughts that's a wsj
story and this next one is concerning
for a couple people here on the panel
vasectomies Rose what 29 into three
months after the end of row the economy
economists wrote that you got yours and
then Mel Gibson will talk about that and
new Surgeon General talked about the
loneliness epidemic and this is the same
person that was supportive of the
shutdown but yeah let me first go to our
sponsor our sponsor today's Masterworks
gank there's a lot of things that's
going on you know when you think when
you think about Investments alternative
Investments are on the rise and one of
the reasons why I like uh Masterworks
and what they do is I'm an art guy I
collect collectible I have a lot of
Collectibles probably 10 million dollars
worth of Collectibles myself it's not as
big as some others but it's you know I
have a good amount and I keep investing
back into it because the Returns on it
are good and many times they beat the S
P 500 the returns and it's a way to
anything that's non-duplicatable asset
I'm interested in it and this is what
Masterworks does now a lot of people say
I can't afford a bank C I can't afford a
Picasso I can't afford an Andy Warhol I
don't have a million bucks I don't have
five million bucks but you can afford to
buy a share of it just like you can't
afford to buy apple as a whole company
but you can buy a share of Apple you can
buy a share of Microsoft you can now buy
a share of my uh Banksy Andy Warhol you
know all these Picasso Arts that they
own so if you haven't yet registered
with these guys
I believe they have over 700 000 members
now and there's a link below in the link
for you to go out there and sign up to
be part of this uh uh once again last
time inflation was this side
Contemporary Art appreciated on an
average ready of 20 per year if you've
not registered with Masterworks click on
the link below to get registered with
those guys okay first story which one do
we want to get into I say we get into
the indictment a uh indictment story
okay first things first the indictment
all right so here we go here are the
charges and how many years Trump faces
in federal Mar-A-Lago indictment New
York Post Story number one retaining
classified document Trump is charged
with hoarding classified material on
Mar-A-Lago with a maximum sentence of 10
years or a fine number two conspiring to
obstruct Justice Trump is accused of
instructing others to mislead government
officials during the retrieval of the
classified documents constituting an
obstruction of justice charge this
carries a maximum sentence of 10 years
or a fine number three withholding a
document investigators allege that Trump
purposefully retained some of the top
secret government documents which is
authorized and it carries a maximum
which unauthorized I'm sorry and carries
a maximum sentence of five years number
four corruptly consuming a document or
record Trump is charged with both
threatening others to mislead a federal
investigation and illegally retaining
classified documents which carries a
punishment up to 20 years conceding a
document in a federal investigation
Trump faces an additional 20 your per
sentence 20-year sentence if convicted
number six scheme to conceal Trump is
Accused to knowingly hiding the
classified documents while serving in a
government branch carrying a maximum of
five years if deemed domestic terrorism
the charge could be as as high as eight
years and last but not least seven false
false statements and a representation
Trump could face charges for lying about
keeping top secret document papers in
his private home with a maximum sentence
of fibers quite frankly all these
numbers are high all they care about is
to be able to put this guy in prison for
about 17 months 19 months that's all
they care about if they can put them in
prison until December of 2024 they're
happy that's what they care about Tom
when you hear these stories what do you
think about well I think about Eric
Adams remember Eric Adams the indictment
that came in New York and it was like he
listed like 14 things was it 14 counts
or something crazy in New York and it
really boiled down to one thing this is
one thing let's take a look at this and
this is what the government does ladies
and gentlemen this is what they do they
cut the onion Into Thin slices and they
keep making you cry over it
think of this what if a teacher said to
you because you yell at the teacher that
says you're staying after school for
charge one interrupting the teacher
charge two raising your voice charge
three yelling at a teacher your parents
would say what the hell are you doing
you're just keeping them after school
for one thing he yelled in class and you
got upset with you how are you keeping
them three days after school and you're
making up these charges that's what
they're doing here watch this retaining
classified documents withholding a
document corrupt concealing a document
concealing a document a federal
investigation scheme to conceal that's
all the same thing hiding a document and
then the other one is he lied and
obstructed Justice they say conspiring
to obstruct Justice false statements
representations to obstruct they're
really saying two things you had
documents and you um you you were not
honest with us about it and they're
trying to cut this thing pbd into
multiple charges that way they can keep
putting the years on it and it gives
them something to settle on
the federal prosecutor here's what they
really want they want a settlement in
which he agrees not to be running and he
agrees to go away that's what the design
is here they're trying to wound His
Image in public I'm not sure they really
want the DeSantis to come out better on
this very politically charged but this
is how the government does it they cut
things into little slices to make it
seem bigger but here's I think Pat
because we were getting on the flight
right I think it's the timing of this
right because Biden unleashedness
indictment on the same day that the
House Republicans were finally able to
publicize the evidence that that 5
million from Ukraine the Barista story
went to to like so when people I tell
people to wake up there is no
coincidence it happens on purpose
they've weaponized the Department of
Justice and it's like think about it we
get on the plane one story comes out we
land that one hits because now what's
the main story Pat it's trump it has
nothing nobody cares about the Biden
situation and Biden is on camera do you
remember that Rob when he when he was
like I'm not they wanted a billion
dollars and he goes I told him guess
what you ain't getting it this right
here unless and you know why Pat unless
they fire the the guy that was going
after Hunter this is the video right
here can you press this is evidence
we've also remember going over
convincing our team our brothers to
convince you know that we should be
providing for loan guarantees and I went
over right I guess the 12th 13th time to
Kiev and uh and I was going supposed to
announce that there was another billion
dollar loan guarantee and I had gotten a
commitment from poroshenko and from uh
yatsenyuk that they would take action
against a state prosecutor and they
didn't wow
they walk out the Press conf said no I
said I'm not gonna or we're not going to
give you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours and the prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money oh son of a
[__]
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid at the time you know the
prosecutor was Pat the guy that was
investigating Hunter and Barista like do
you when when are people going to wake
up and be like bro that the proof is
right in front of your face and nothing
happens you have that article that just
came out by the way this is the one from
Joe Biden allegedly paid five million
dollars by barisma executive as part of
a bribery scheme according to FBI
document this is not like it it keep
going Lord let me just look at President
John by five let me read that whole
thing by executive
of the Ukraine natural gas firm barisma
where his son Biden Hunter sat on the
board of confidential human source told
FBI during gay June 2020 interview
resource just familiar with told Fox
News digital the sources brief Fox
literature the FBI generated fd-1023
form alleging a criminal bribery scheme
between then Vice President Joe Biden
and a foreign National that involved
influence over U.S policy decisions the
form dated June 20 June 30th 2020 is the
FBI's interview with a highly credible
confidential Source Who detailed
multiple meetings and conversations he
or she had with a top resume executive
over the course of several years
starting 2015. is there anything else
below that for us to see I mean that in
itself is plenty ain't it of course it
is it's good it's like it's like it's
not rumors of Russian collusion and all
the BS you're seeing a video of a guy
saying pay per pay per play you know I
mean and you have to fire somebody
that's investigating my son Pat and the
proof is right there and nothing happens
that's why it's so frustrating for the
average person because it's like you're
the left the left runs the show and by
the way the FD FBI Pat sent somebody up
that recorded it right so a assignment
officer and a superior agreed to take
fd-1023 the FBI will agree not to even
talk to people at times when they're
trying to cover up but they actually so
an assignment officer and a superior
actually agreed yeah let's go file it
that's permanently filed
that's permanently filed yeah that's
that's in the record now and I want 10
20. I want to show this this just
happened this week check this out this
is kind of weird when you see this here
play this clip if you have it Rob
uh disturbing and the reaction and the
answer at the end I think I showed this
to you guys this is amazing watch this
go ahead no opportunities respond to a
former White House stenographer who this
month outed you as a Anonymous senior
Administration official who reporters on
Air Force 2 in route to Ukraine in 2014.
um he says that you spoke about giving
Aid to the Ukrainian national gas
industry just days after the first or
the second son had secretly joined the
board of Ukrainian gas company he says
he considers you part of the corrupt
influence Pelicans peddling conspiracy
he wants to testify to Delaware grand
jury about it do you have a response to
that and were you part of a corrupt
influence peddling operation involving
Vice family and Ukraine or any other
country no no no
by the way look at the blink rate the
FBI profilers will tell you when the
blink rate starts going up is where
you're you're you have mental stress and
and seeing that the point that we said
yesterday about that journalism is dead
he says no nobody goes into a frenzy and
goes well wait a minute wait what do you
nobody says nothing and they move on to
the next story tell you what the music
they played in that video was very you
would just know he's guilty just by the
music all those X-Files yeah well here's
my thoughts on the Trump situation was
um you know a lot of people use the word
Witch Hunt right and um I have the
definition of that I'm not saying that
is a full-on Witch Hunt but it
definitely smells witch-hunty yeah right
I don't know if that's witchy version
but definitely spells witch Hunty the
definition of a Witch Hunt is a campaign
directed against a person a group
holding unorthodox or unpopular views we
could have debate of whether his views
are unpopular they're certainly
unorthodox uh but that's what's going on
there and you know it came from when
witches who were not doing anything
witchcrafty were burned at the
[__] stake uh for allegedly
doing things so it definitely feels like
that we had the conversation with the
two FBI agent whistleblowers the other
day and the term weaponized and
politicized was being thrown around like
a football left and right well for Biden
I don't think it's the Witch Hunt I
think it's really the question of which
bribe yeah exactly exactly so exactly we
learned we learned with Trump and
Trump's defense that Russia the Russia
gate turned out to be NADA Ukraine stuff
didn't really turn out to be anything
Hillary the impeachment stuff didn't
really turn out to be anything the
Stormy Daniels hush money we'll see what
happens with that seems very Petty but I
think this is just going to be a slow
drip you mentioned Eric Adams I think
you meant Alvin Bragg the the state of
New York that is coming after him
obviously this and then we're gonna see
what happens with the Georgia situation
that's him on tape asking to find uh 11
000 something something votes uh I think
this comes into three camps uh kind of
like what we talked about with Tate
there's the people who are automatically
assuming that Tate is guilty without any
evidence and they've basically anchored
to that position there's nothing you
could tell them to prove them otherwise
there's the other Camp that's like he's
the man he's the top G you can't show me
anything that he's done and uh I have
his back totally understand that and
then there's the independent free
thinkers that are basically let's see
what happens here and I think that's
exactly what's playing out with the
Trump Situation Number One and you have
the mega base that is [__] pissed
okay there's nobody on the on the on the
right side of things that is happy about
this they completely are on the camp
that this is a freaking Witch Hunt I
don't know if you saw what Mark Levin
had to say dude went off steam coming
from his ears people are freaking pissed
about this we talked about the country
being divided and divisive this ain't
helping whatsoever you want to pull up
Rock living keep what you just had there
no no put your head on so then you have
the Democratic laughter that woke left
if you go there they are ecstatic
they're they're happy to see this is
what they wanted they want more of this
it's like Trump porn and uh The Fetish
is not is not going down whatsoever then
you have the people
um and I would say I'm in that camp
that's like all right this seems a
little witch-hunty let's let the facts
play out let's see what happens here
um this is you know you put up a poll up
there how much you trust the justice
department I I'm assuming that there's
going to be a lot of people that do not
trust what is going on here and the
record is not good for what's going on
in Trump World As far as going after the
guy and really finding nothing but you
touch on it pat they're gonna stop at
nothing uh and then 18 months from now
if he's not winning the election or even
running the election they're going to be
very happy to see this last point this
is the cover of Time Magazine this week
right I don't know if you can see this
it is a picture of uh Ron DeSantis
um the sanctimonious and it's what Ron
DeSantis means for America and it is him
peeling an orange you could touch on a
double layered in Florida the orange the
Sunshine State uh but also there's a big
bad orange man that he's looking to
unpeel and take down so I think that's
sort of the media's narrative is that
they would love to see Trump out of this
thing and DeSantis in there let's not
forget one thing at the end of the day
this is the first time in this nation's
history that a former president has been
formally charged by the federal
government the Stormy Daniels hush money
situation was New York State Alvin Bragg
everything with that he campaigned on
that at the end of the day I think it's
a sad situation I think at the end of
the day the number one word that keeps
popping up whether you're on the left or
on the right is accountability what's
the accountability here Trump being held
accountable is biting being held
accountable is accountability Beyond is
being distributed evenly uh I know a lot
of people on the right do not think
that it's just one side accountability
like one side gets away with literally
murder one side is just it's not just
one side it's trump it does all Trump
dude it's literally all Trump and I
might my question was bro when when are
Americans actually going to do something
all we do is talk Pat all the right does
is bark when are the people actually
gonna get involved and I'm not talking
about January 6 BS where they show up
and FBI agents are like hey let's run
into the capital I'm talking about like
in Europe when Brazil and all those
protests there was millions and millions
of people in the street saying enough is
enough what do you think it's going to
take for us like what Pat every day is
another story of Biden can do whatever
he wants they can do whatever he wants
Hillary can do Russia collusion and all
that when when when is going to be the
breaking point or are we too soft and
going back to what Tay always talks
about the masculine men they're they're
getting rid of all these guys those guys
are just soft now nobody's going in the
streets it's just I'm gonna post a vlog
I'm gonna go on and I'm gonna post
something on Instagram when is enough
Adam what do you think is going to be
that breaking ball that pattern Pat into
this but I think he already hit on it
once Trump is no longer in the race boom
they're done with the guy but while he's
in this race they do not want to see
this guy be the president period end of
story they they will go after DeSantis
but at a tent of what they're doing with
Trump not not even close right uh again
for me one of the things we were talking
about is in Glendale Unified School
District by the way Glendale if you're
listening to this I'm talking about you
on Tates uh into interview and we have a
lot of respect for those parents man I
mean I I saw one of these clips uh uh uh
which which I'll send you rob here in a
minute and we'll talk about that the
biggest thing is you not being afraid of
taking a stand you're not being afraid
of taking a stand against what's taking
place there's a part of it where if
Glendale Unified School District is sick
of it if they're sick of what's taking
place if they're sick of all the mess
that's taking place you have to go on a
strike it got so bad that the board
member shows up and says hey what do we
need to do to get you guys to stop
protesting you know what the mother said
now what do you want to do what about
when we first ask you and we we talked
about this you didn't listen to us now
you want us to stop now because it's
embarrassing what you guys are doing no
now we're going to keep talking about
this until you stop and one guy comes in
saying we have you know uh death upon
Christian fascists I don't know if you
saw this clip or not rob
I showed it to you guys this one guy
gets up there and says death upon
Christian fascist and he's a guy that's
holding uh if I can find this clip I
think I retweeted it or something this
guy's got very very good clips about
this anyways I'll find it here in a
minute we'll go through it but but
people have to uh when you do something
like this you're eventually going to
wake people up and they're eventually
gonna say I am not going to tolerate
this this is Glendale Glendale right now
if you look at this look at the fights
if you can click on a suit it can hear
the noise look what the guy says turn on
the audio yeah go ahead oh wow dude look
at that they're giving you audio because
you might you know that that's antifa
too Pat yeah Tifa was there getting
their asses
this is where you grew up yes listen I'm
there if there's one thing about
Armenians if you do anything
to their mothers and their kids it's
game over Yep this is a very different
kind of a culture this is the types of
people you want to have drinks with you
want to have conversation with you want
to spend time with but God forbid you do
anything to their kids and they're
starting to see it right now it's Common
Sense by the way don't mess with my kids
one of the mothers asked the question I
have to find these clips to show it to
you one of the mothers asked the
question and says you know uh uh why why
are we showing why do we have to teach a
four-year-old about what a transgender
is why do we have to teach a
four-year-old a four-year-old what does
a four-year-old have to learn about
being a transgender nothing a 40 year
old has nothing to do to learn about
what a transgender is but they're doing
these kinds of things one Armenian guy
was standing across a um
a standing across the sky and this other
guy was saying you know death death upon
Christian fascists and the guy turns
around and says he says really he says
you want to burn the American flag he
says yes he says you want to burn the
American flag do you have that clip did
I send it to you or not I wish I haven't
showed that it was incredible he says
you want to burn the American flag he
says why is it why is it such a big deal
if we burn the uh uh the LGBT the pride
flag but not a big deal if you burn the
American flag why is that okay and
anyways it was a back and forth with
them but my point to you is you got to
stand up for your values and principles
especially at a point like this when
insanity is taking place and the biggest
thing about that is and this is
something that I've learned repeatedly
being here at valuetainment why is it
that people who are not born here not
from America that came here that that
earned the right to be here are freaking
obsessed with America why because they
know what it's like the rest of the
world they know what it's like not to
have a voice not to have your freedoms
to be locked up in jail for [__] to
not to have food on the plate not that I
have an opportunity to not have money
and they come here and they deeply with
gratitude and appreciation love what
America is about then you have these
yahoos that are born in America and they
just play the [__] victim role and
all they do is want to hate on America
this is why when Sebastian Gorka was
here we just made a call he said he said
this came down to two things two camps
the people that love America and the
people that hate America want to destroy
America and it's sad to say but that's
becoming more and more true every single
freaking day I found the clip can you
play this clip watch this guy here
buddies this is it okay make it make it
bigger and let's get the audio Rob if we
can
uh tell me the audio works on this one
okay go for it
I agree to death to America but I also
agree death to Christian fascists this
is a White Guy saying death to Christian
fascists okay keep playing it
[Music]
about
[Applause]
listen to the average person tell me who
you want on your side tell me who you
want to be friends with tell me who you
want as a citizen tell me who's a net
positive to your country tell me who's
more grateful tell me who's more
thankful for your country tell me who's
better for you tell me who should we we
should make more to a hero who should we
protect more this clown or the other guy
that's trying to defend his kids do we
not value great parents great fathers
Great Men great leaders that are willing
to stand up for this incredible country
do we value that then turn that man into
a hero now by the way I would love to
have a
it was a whole different conversation I
was having with Merle tickling and my
sister about doing an event in Glendale
at the biggest Hall and bringing all
these parents because I got a message
for these Armenian parents that are
doing this and and I think uh anyways
that's a whole different thing I don't
want to get into it right now but all
I'm saying is I am so proud
so proud and maybe proud is one word but
I want to add another one I am so proud
and
honored to have half of my blood be
Armenian to see the representation of
these incredible fathers and mothers
that are brave to stand up to this
pathetic hypocrisy this [__] woke
agenda that has convinced so many people
to think this is noble and we ought to
sit there and be tolerant about it I
respect you for fighting to every single
Armenian parent to every single Armenian
individual that you got a sibling a
brother a sister an aunt and uncle there
was a 90 year old grandmother standing
there talking to one of these clowns in
a very calm way like what are you doing
I got so much respect for you guys keep
doing what you're doing you know how
they say that we're living in a clown
world every Up Is Down left is right up
this is just a case example exhibit a
you have an American born and raised in
America hates America wants to burn the
USA flag you have an immigrant an
Armenian immigrant speaking in a accent
defending the flag one is trying to burn
the American flag one is basically
saying do not touch this [__] Flag
okay I'm not gonna touch your LGBT woke
do your thing unicorn don't touch his
flag and you can tell the the the in his
voice he meant it of course he would die
for his beliefs because he knows what
it's like on the other side of the
country other side of the world it's
it's really pathetic it's a clown
[__] world it really is and if
anybody doesn't understand what's going
on on Twitter here and having the
ability to see unedited videos so you
can see what is being said when is being
said this is not getting edited and put
on mainstream media this is not going on
the news on the news they portray it as
a bunch of freak parents that are upset
that are against Progressive values and
the rights of other people baloney what
these people are is upset about what
you're trying to teach their kids and
thanks to Twitter you've got all sorts
of these these wonderful accounts that I
was looking at yesterday Pat that was it
was not cut they're just saying look at
what this person said look at what this
person said she were able to see the
truth of what's going on there including
you know that this this woke woman who
actually stood and was speaking to the
uh school board and she mentioned the
genocide and denied it so he had a
genocide denier on top of this hitting
to the core of something happened to the
um Armenian community that we needed
we've got St Patrick's Day if we've got
Martin Luther King day we need a day on
the American calendar for to recognize
what happened with The Armenian Genocide
and you got this woman with the and I'm
going to call her trans because she had
the balls to stand there and and make a
comment and invoke a comment about the
genocide while she's making a comment so
she's clearly poking and triggering
these parents that are outside and I was
thankful that I could see a 360 degree
view of all these folks to see really
what was happening there because this is
not the coverage you were getting on the
media no that's that's this is again
respect you guys for what you're doing
to every single Armenian and by the way
this is this isn't just Armenian I I
know a lot of Hispanics they don't stand
up for this
I know our company half of it is
Hispanic and I'm talking every kind of
Hispanic they don't stand up for this
stuff they do not stand up for this
stuff okay this this is not the game
they play this is not what they want to
do they have strong values and
principles they don't support decisions
like this by the way we're talking about
Trump we're talking about Biden I posted
a poll on Twitter can you go to my
Twitter account if you could just write
there go to my Twitter account and re
refresh it refresh it so all this stuff
can be no no go back to yeah just
refresh it from the top there you go and
then go to the poll and zoom in a little
bit I asked the following question
how much do you trust the current
justice system in America okay
the answers are uh uh uh uh pick one of
them by the way just vote on one of them
yourself Riley okay
3574 people voted 44 minutes ago
61.3 percent said zero
27.3 said minimal that means 89
said minimal to zero eighty nine percent
said minimal to zero nine point three
percent said somewhat 2.1 percent said
fully I can guarantee you the fully are
100 vaccinated and they wear masks in
the car they were wearing masks when
they put the phone one right there by
the way so that just kind of tells you
hilarious the state of the the current
economy anyways we can go to the next
topic I'll finish it up with you here
you were going to say something well I
mean it's it's like I like just peel
this back a little bit I have
conversations with people of on all
political sides of the aisle okay and
what I like having conversations with is
people that are not Trump fans Not TR
not Maga world people that voted for
Biden and say what do you think about
what's going on here what do you think
about this situation what do you think
about what's happening with Trump what
do you think about what's happening with
the LGBT woke the problem that I have is
we're so polarized it's like if you
voted for Biden you must be a gay
liberal Democrat obviously right it's
like we voted for for Trump you must
have been there storming the capital on
January 6th it's a broad spectrum and
what I like understanding is when people
are like yeah I voted for Biden but I
don't really like what's going on here
on the left here it's not you know I've
got kids in school I don't like this
[__] and I'm not a trump supporter but I
don't support this and it's very nuanced
debate here same with this it's like I
know plenty of democrat people they're
not woke antifa people just like I know
Penny plenty of you know DeSantis type
people who are on the the Maga Camp it's
a very nuanced debate here but when
everybody across the aisle everyone
across the Spectrum politically is
seeing something like this and they're
like this is ridiculous this is freaking
ridiculous that's that's when you
understand that that it's really a
situation that is just completely all
right so this week multiple people made
announcements that they're running Chris
Christie I don't know if you've heard of
them before he announced he's running
he's the former Governor of New Jersey
uh uh Mike Pence announced he's running
as well Insider came out uh I showed it
to you guys yesterday when Insider on
their Instagram profile when Mike
Pence's announcement was made I I don't
know what the article said but it was
not good uh they said something like
Mike Pence made an announcement that
he's running and nobody cared I thought
he was leading in the polls Mike let me
let me read the article of what it said
if I have and he did say something pedal
in the lines that if Trump is the
nominee he kind of will support it here
you go it says Pence made an
announcement but no one cares about Mike
Pence this is Insider Insider is liberal
it's Insider business if you want to go
to it Insider business if you go to
you'll see they said nobody cared uh uh
nobody cared about
what do you have to say and then Tim
Scott goes on The View and rails against
the host uh offensive comments about him
he crushed it by the way okay when he
went on uh you can just zoom in real
quick Rob just zoom in right there
yourself and you'll be able to see it no
one cares about Mike Pence Insider
saying that okay but the YouTube story
is kind of weird on what came out this
last week this came out of nowhere okay
one announcement like this was made by
YouTube YouTube Reckless to stop
policing false claims on Election fraud
Biden's campaign says this is a reuter
story The Biden campaign strongly
criticizes YouTube's decision to seize
policing false claims about the election
fraud demon get reckless in warning of
potential violence YouTube announces
policy change citing concerns about
curtailing political speech while
acknowledging that removing content did
come back some misinformation the
platform's decision to stop removing
false claims related to the 2020
election is seen as controversial and
concerning Biden's campaign spokesperson
Kevin Munoz emphasizes that the policy
changes does not erase the fact that
Biden legitimately won the 2020 election
expressing concern about the role of
social media companies and spreading
lies during that period now here's the
part when you see a story like this
um why is YouTube doing this okay let's
let's go logical let's go in every way
we want first of all YouTube's ad
revenue is down 2.6 the highest drop
they've ever had from the day YouTube
got started first time ever their ad
revenue is down two point right there
zoom in TechCrunch YouTube continues to
see ad Revenue decline 2.6 percent year
over year this is not a good look for
YouTube okay because they have investors
YouTube uh you know it shows the results
there where they were at and where
they're at right now so they're sitting
around saying what the hell is going on
rumble on the other side keep signing
people left and right okay
Rumble is indirectly holding these guys
accountable Twitter is indirectly
holding these guys accountable if God
forbid
report comes out that Tucker's show on
Twitter made him 2.2 million dollars in
a month or something like that YouTube
could be crushed big time and what I
mean by YouTube could be crushed here's
the thing nobody thinks about okay
nobody thinks about nobody realizes that
the biggest thing about bullies is
bullies are only bullies until somebody
stands up to them and you know what is
the typical mindset of a bully what is
the typical mindset of a bully the
typical mindset of a bully is that he is
going to have he or she is going to have
that kind of power forever and it's the
biggest lie if you have a monopoly on
social media
you feel like we can have a control of
this forever they had it for a few years
they don't have it anymore if we have a
monopoly on mainstream media we can do
whatever we want oh yeah see what's
changing if we have a monopoly we can
push the agenda with ESG and our name is
Blackrock Vanguard and State Street oh
really okay you keep doing I see what's
happening right and we'll cover a story
with Wall Street Journal if this ESG
stuff is working but the point here with
YouTube I applaud them for going this
direction if YouTube If YouTube chooses
to go back to allowing people from both
sides
to go and comment without inciting
violence but they're going out there and
giving their thoughts their opinions
they allow that to stay YouTube will be
King Kong again but if they don't this
is by far the worst time ever for
YouTube to play the same political games
they played in June of 2020 when they
saw listen I remember one time Mario and
I sitting are watching YouTube I don't
know how many videos were taken out on
YouTube suddenly for us 10 20 30 40. I
remember one time and it was like oh boy
we did this interview taken out we did
this interview taken out we did this and
everything our RFK interview where he
talks about what he thought happened to
his father and who killed them you know
that was taken down our RFK interview we
had a couple million views after a week
or two was taking out whatever the
timeline was it could have been a month
or two before they took it down but if
YouTube goes this direction good for
them if they don't capitalism is here
capitalism Works competition is going to
take their lunch not because I said so
because it always has since day one
especially with companies that become
arrogant thinking they have a monopoly
and monopolies don't last forever do you
think it'll help out you think it's too
late for them because now there's
Twitter and there's all these ah they're
so massive it's not too late they have
everybody I mean they have Mr Beast they
have they have everybody they have music
they have their they have so many the
kids p and by the way here's the other
part you know how much the biggest
YouTuber made last year 58 million
dollars you know what Jake Paul made off
YouTube last year 45 million bucks you
know that that guy that does the toy
reviews you know the guy yeah what's his
name the the uh Ryan Ryan's you know
what Ryan made last year can you put
Ryan's income last year Ryan made 28
million dollars last year of YouTube
Right parents made twice I mean 28
million dollars I want to say he made
love what's the number uh uh can you see
the income what he made last year on a
list of top 10 biggest YouTubers you'll
see he made 28 million bucks I think
that's old
and Jake Paul made 45 million off
YouTube YouTube is still I mean listen
Jake Paul made 45 million rumble's
revenue is roughly 100 million revenue
and one of YouTubers Talent made 45
million that's a that's a big difference
and Rumble has to figure out I'm sorry
35 million dollars in earnings my
apologies I was off by seven million
bucks but the point is everything
yeah there you go 35 million bucks so
the point is there's still King Kong
but King Kong is starting to realize hey
man maybe we have to allow capitalism to
his part and people got to have
different opposing opinions Tom well
there also is something luring in the
background it's called section 230 and
section 230 is the Safe Harbor law that
allows YouTube and Twitter and others to
actually moderate and they are shielded
federally from liability for what
happens on freedom of speech and what
they don't want they also do not want a
Conservative Republican to mess with
Section 230. users and services cannot
be sued and that's what they want Tom
they have their and so what they're
trying to do is they're trying to play
nice because they don't want section 230
to be changed if it does change it
changes their liability it changes what
they can and can't do it makes it that
if they were to censor someone they're
actually centering free speech and
exposes them to a lot of things they
want section 230 to say hey YouTube do
whatever you do you operate as a
publisher
cut people off allow people there and
then massive Point you're making and
then and then but you want to be able to
want to be a liberal Voice censor all
the conservatives that's your choice
YouTube they don't want Ron DeSantis or
um a certain Donald J Trump to come in
and say
we have fixed in section 230. I'm
tearing it in half yeah that's not what
they want and by the way it it's it's in
the gun sights of um a lot of
conservatives and yes I said gun sites
there you go Tom you do a Bill Clinton
impersonation way better than Trump you
wanna try that again Vinnie does it way
better you're crazy if I was President
all this man that wouldn't happen there
you go there he is there he is guys
let's go to the next story here so
California governor Gavin Newsom
proposes 28 amendment to the
Constitution to combat
gun violence this is a USA Today story
um so uh Newsome proposes 200
Constitution aimed at addressing gun
violence the proposed amendment includes
raising the minimum age to purchase a
gun from 18 to 21 implementing Universal
background checks establishing waiting
periods to gun purchases and prohibiting
civilians from buying assault weapons
newsom's proposal seeks to strike a
balance between enacting Common Sense
gun safety laws while respecting the
Second Amendment in America is going to
owning tradition adding a constitutional
amendment would require significant
support and ratification from two-thirds
of Congress and three-thirds of the
state three-fourths of the state making
the process challenging Newsome uh uh uh
to collaborate with Grassroots Sports
Newsome's plans to collaborate with
Grassroots supporters elected leaders
and coalitions Across the Nation to
gather support for similar resolutions
in other states Tom what's what's
Newsome doing with this here well first
of all this is a this is a standard
political plank populist statement he's
speaking to the liberal base about gun
control and what he's trying to do is
put safety front and center I think
people should be 21. don't you think
that's a good idea you know how do you
argue against that no no a 10 year old
should have a gun it's hard to argue
that side then what about background
checks what about gun shows selling a
private cell out of the trunkier car
should there be a background check and a
you know you have to fill out a form to
sell your car to somebody and drop it
off at DMV why shouldn't you have to do
that with a gun all of that sounds good
except there's a trojan horse here the
Trojan Horse is prohibiting civilians
from buying assault weapons and inside
it the definition of assault weapon will
expand and expand and expand you know an
automatic weapon classic machine gun
it's an assault weapon and pretty soon
your Remington 410 bore that you're
hunting pheasant with will be called an
assault weapon that's the Trojan Horse
but the odds of getting this through all
the states is very very low what he's
doing is talking to the liberal base and
he's trying to plant the seeds this is
one of the planks I have and I'm running
on gun control running against shootings
this is one of the planks in his
campaign he's trying to get the uh also
get the DNC to pay attention to him and
to allow him to be a candidate for uh
president if they uh flip the switch on
Joe Biden but the com but what's in
there this is a trojan horse the assault
weapon list will just keep expanding
that's the design you know you use the
word that I think is very apropos you
said he's appealing to the populist base
because gun control and figuring out
these [__] mass shooting situations
actually is very popular now I do agree
with you that there's definitely a
trojan horse aspect of this and the the
the concern certainly from the two-way
people is that they're coming after your
guns uh I don't think that's the on the
agenda but if that's what you feel
totally entitled to that but I do think
there is a deep yearning in this country
to figure this out guys something needs
to get done here the status quo of just
a shooting every 21 hours RFK mentioned
this he said what in Switzerland there
hasn't been a mass shooting like this in
schools or in general 21 20 years 21
years and this happens every 21 hours
here in America now is Gavin Newsom
approach the perfect situation the
perfect approach arguable
um we'll see but I actually applaud him
for doing something about this now are
there deeper motivations here is this an
appeal to the DNC to become the next
president we all know that Biden is
running on empty yet he's the front
runner here
um I actually I think uh when I think of
fake politician the first name that
comes to mind is Gavin Newsom but there
is some genuine desire to get this
figured out uh because I the the the
normalcy and just the hey yeah another
shooting is actually disgusting but
don't you think that it go okay the guns
again it's always going to be about the
guns but what I think RFK even said too
is when are we going to address the
mental health situation the fact that in
in the past what 20 30 years to get into
the mindset to take a gun just a regular
person they always interview the the
students around this person the majority
of the time they're like we had no idea
what makes somebody go into a school and
shoot children okay and that's something
where your brain and that's when the
drugs start coming in the the pro
whatever all the joint and all the pros
the pressure for the kids and then but
guess what you can't talk [__] about the
drugs and get into them mental side
because big Pharma is making billions of
pumping these drugs into these kids you
can't go against these guys how much do
we learn Adam I fully agree with you
yeah to me the mental health situation
of the drug situation is Step 10. okay
meaning like that's not gonna happen
overnight of course some sort of
sensible gun control some sort of
situation you know I'm an advocate of
two things why aren't police in front of
schools why aren't people in front of
schools you know many individuals make a
great case of like CNN you've got armed
guards here Fox News you got armed
guards here buildings have armed guards
why don't we have that yeah uh and it's
why don't we have that in front of us it
said something during the Twitter spaces
he said if he were to be president he
would treat schools like they were in
reports yeah have you ever seen a mass
shooting at
compared to the mass shootings that
things that happen at schools but that
was step one was treat them like yeah
exactly and yet mental health and then
my second point was and I know this is
controversial these families of these
Mass Shooters there needs to be
accountability with these families okay
I'm not saying you need to lock them up
they need to go to jail for this
but they the families of these people
that do Matt you could kill 50 people
and then the one kid just rots in jail
what about the family what about the
people that raised this kid their legacy
their name their bloodline there needs
to be some accountability with these
people they're raising Savages yeah you
know listen we talked about this yeah
for me I think one of one of the most
important candidates right now who's
talking about stuff that nobody else was
talking about but it's necessary as RFK
and RFK he had us live on Twitter space
and his life was
300 000 people were on musca or you know
talked about uh a bunch of different
things Elon Musk closed today Twitter
space event in 2024 presidential candle
RFK where Kennedy praised musk for
defending free speech and rescuing
American democracy however Twitter
criticized musk for giving a platform to
Kennedy who has been banned from social
platforms uh uh for spreading
misinformation during the event Kennedy
spread misinformation uh about kova 19
calling it a bio weapons problem and
accused traditional media organizations
of being propaganda vessels he also
blamed President Joe Biden for steering
Democrats towards war in the midst of
the event musk revealed that Twitter's
Revenue was down by half suggesting
potential Financial challenges for the
social media platform let's stay on RFK
here
so this guy explains how you know what's
the difference between us and
Switzerland 21 years 21 hours right we
had a school Mass shooting 21 hours ago
and there was one in Virginia I think
two days ago and he says Switzerland
hasn't had a school Mass shooting for 21
years what's the difference they have
the same amount of guns per capita give
or take so then the question that became
with Tate when the question was you know
what's changed between now and 1950
right what's changed and that led to an
incredible conversation if you pull up
what I just sent you Rob because the
question was well do people own more
guns today than before well no
percentage of households in United
States owning one or more firearms from
1972 till today it's about the same look
at that it was even higher in 1970 to 43
we even went as high as 47 percent in
1990 under Clinton under Bush senior I
believe right that's Bush senior yeah
under Bush senior so 47 and we were as
low as
37 2013 that's what under Obama and then
37 also the lowest under Trump 2019. so
the two lowest times of gun ownership
the last 50 years was under Trump and
under uh Obama so one cannot say well
people own more guns today than ever
before but there's a couple things that
change one do you know there's only two
countries in the world that can
advertise pick Pharma one is us one is
New Zealand do you know when that law
was passed uh Rob if he can go Google
when did the law pass uh to Big Pharma
advertise U.S just type in big Pharma
advertised U.S law it was I believe in
1985. well that's a big difference
because they could advertise in 1985 and
versus they can in 1980 there's a 1987
okay 1987 when that passed well that's a
big difference that they can start
advertising right okay now go and take a
look at when Prozac came out go look at
when Prozac came out what year did
Prozac come out I think it's 88 or 89 is
when they started there you go 88 yeah
88 88 January 88 is when they started
selling it okay so so far from 70 till
today what changed one advertising of
big Pharma which those guys started
making more money so CNN all these MSNBC
all these big media companies are
getting their money from what big Pharma
too Prozac we didn't have something like
Prozac you know it's pretty bad one on
these drugs can you type in drugs that
the disclaimer says suicide drugs
disclaimer suicide uh uh suicide
tendency if you can type that and bring
it up uh uh uh uh drugs that say this if
you take this there's a possibility of
suicide uh Pharmaceuticals maybe type in
Pharmaceuticals instead of putting drugs
Pharmaceuticals so you you buy these
Pharmaceuticals and in there it says
there's a side effect that they go side
effects of suicide let's see what comes
up go a little lower go a little because
the first one is a hotline go a little
lower Hopson go a little lower uh
medications with suicide risk there you
go click on that zoom in
but just click on it or no
yes it's loading okay so you got all
these medications that people are taking
why would they put disclaimer of suicide
on there why would you do that what's
the purpose of putting that in there
medications here's a list of medications
that have been linked to suicidal
thoughts and behavior Accutane a skin
drug benzyl okay look at all those lists
there on uh uh keep going the list goes
on and on I don't know how to pronounce
that the picot whatever that thing is I
think that's like a Zoloft type of a
thing that's for bipolar right keep
going Lord Prozac right there okay
Prozac
Suicidal Tendencies right what else do
you have there that Suicidal Tendencies
keep going okay I mean listen probably
not a good idea to allow these guys to
advertise probably not a bad idea for
the next president to say hey guess what
moving forward big Pharma you can't
advertise anymore why not there's 200
countries in the world only two
countries allowed to advertise Us in New
Zealand we're not going to advertise no
more well that's you can't do that I
understand you're not going to like it
because lobbyists are going to go crazy
but we got to cut the stuff so I think
there's certain things that has changed
from 72 or 1950 till today that they
have to pay attention to end let's not
forget during covet what they did
closing everybody down shutting
everybody down stay home don't go out in
to the point where I'll give you an
article here next at the attorney
surgeon attorney general came out and is
talking about the loneliness epidemic no
wonder this happened you're the one that
said stay home that was your idea now
you're saying it's bad there's a lot of
people that said it was bad we're like
no no it's the right thing to do now it
wasn't the right thing to do you yeah
well it's not just suicide I think
that's one component of it I mean the
list here is is very long depression
anxiety restlessness trouble sleeping
panic attacks anger irritability
agitation aggression dangerous impulses
extreme increases in activity talking I
think the common thing here is you hear
when people are pilled out they turn
into what zombies yeah okay and when you
when you're a zombie you have what is
known as apathy you don't care you don't
care whether you live or die you don't
care if other people live or die and it
is it that is what happens when you are
pilled out your Pros act out and all
these pills you know Pat was going A
through Z here the list was too long to
even read all the all these drugs here
now back to RFK what's the exact
opposite of apathy empathy understanding
his appeal to people he says listen
I understand these people I understand
gold called gun culture we just we just
went down the list here was as low as 37
as high as 44. 40 of Americans have guns
it is what it is okay that number
changes and goes up and down a little
bit but 40 of Americans have guns to
speak to his empathy and to speak to his
credibility and to speak to his
authority on this situation if you
recall this he said listen and he
downplayed it it was so incredible he
goes listen I've lost two family members
to gun violence oh really what family
members how about freaking JFK and his
father and his father Bobby Kennedy it's
like if there's anybody his father
there's and his uncle there's anybody
that has the authority that has The
credibility and the empathy to speak
about things like that it is RFK and Pat
I'm So speaking of RFK I am so happy
that he he's because mind you I never
thought I'd be saying this about a
Democrat I genuinely generally like what
he's saying and what he's doing and both
you know how lucky he is thank God thank
God that it's 2023 and we have camera
phones and cameras everywhere and it's
not 1963 where the only person that had
a camera was Abraham is a Bruder because
him talking this type of mess against
Kohler Point Pat against the media
against Biden against corruption he
would have been taken out too sweet bro
but thank God for for technology and
where we are right now that he can say
these things and mind you I think he's
such a big threat to the left I'm
interested to see what they're going to
do Pat to try to take his ass down like
they're taking and this goes back to my
initial point just because you have a d
to the next of your name does not mean
you don't have credibility just like if
you have an R next to your name doesn't
mean that you're some right-wing
extremist it's a very nuanced argument
here it's a very nuanced situation and
you look at people like Tulsi gabbard
who we had on less than a month ago
former Democrat very credible RFK
arguably the legacy of all legacies of
Democrats Kennedy family very credible
definitely shaking things up even Joe
manchin you know I'm a big fan of his uh
it's it just the polarization of the of
the of the politics these days once you
get through the r d situation you
realize let me see the substance that
this person is talking about someone
like RFK is Making Waves in a big way
you know there's been a lot of
discussion and you know people say oh
it's tin hat and conspiracy theorists to
talk about the uni party that that say
look you know the Democrats and public
and Republicans are basically the same
underneath and you have a Maga side over
here and then you have a Bernie side
over here but then there's this cloud in
the middle that kind of goes along with
each other on drug advertising and a lot
of major initiatives
um and then no less than the Wall Street
Journal just had an opinion piece
yesterday or today I think it may have
been today talking about you know is it
time for an American Independent party
and talking about a lot of the ways and
things that are happening so maybe the
common sense starts to come out that the
common sense and common American starts
to come out in the form of a a a a true
Independent party and maybe there's
there's deeper truths about out you know
the whole concept of the unit party
underneath with the extremes at The
Princess Pat let me tee this up for you
because the video that you did about
being a free thinker and being an
outsider is so apropos these days you
have insiders the swamp and you have
Outsiders that shake things up and you
compared the Kennedy family to the Trump
family and being anti-establishment I
think it's a very important uh it's the
hardest position to take it's the
hardest position to take because it
comes with the most hate easiest
position to take is establishment follow
uh follow the herd follow everybody it's
safe you got support you've got back up
to go against the establishment are you
kidding me who who has been actually
think about this who has been the
biggest presidents that have been
anti-establishment presidents Trump
obviously who else Trump and JFK those
are the top of the list and then you
have like one of them win against his
you know saying what are you guys doing
we gotta we gotta let these guys free
what are you talking about you know he
they didn't like him they didn't like
what Reagan was doing they didn't like
you know there's a lot of these guys
that you look at that they go after but
uh you know it's going to be interesting
seeing what happens Trump's going to
keep saying what he's saying uh uh uh he
he talked about the Tweet out there but
anyways let's go to the next story here
next story time I want to go into a
couple business stories here with you uh
one is somewhat business actually let's
just go to the business one here first
half the world's biggest companies are
downsizing office space amid hybrid
working this is an Insider story here we
go
um
defined as half the world's largest
companies defined as those with over 50
000 employees plan to downsize their
office space by 10 to 20 percent by 2026
that's a real number by the way as
hybrid working becomes more prevalent
while many companies are embracing
hybrid work 31 are adopting an office
first approach the shift in Office Space
strategy is driven by a broader range of
business factors beyond the pandemic
with companies seeking to optimize their
office usage and offer flexibility to
employees however 55 of all survey
companies anticipate increasing their
office footprints in the next three
years particularly mid-sized companies
so bigger companies are downsizing
smaller to mid-sized companies are
getting more office space Tom when you
see this what do you think about with
this article well the first thing is you
know your government under the cover of
covid you know sort of was pushing the
agenda for work from home and forcing
lockdowns and what they have unwittingly
done has triggered a waterfall and I'm
speaking to you Joe Biden he's triggered
a waterfall that is about to be a
Calamity in commercial real estate
because now the companies are saying
well maybe I can't there's two sides to
it there are companies that are asking
people to come back to work and we're
seeing those
um announcements every day Apple says
people got to come back to work Amazon
says then all the people get upset well
then what you don't see is Underneath It
All is the companies that say well me we
maybe I can make some of the remote work
for cost reasons and those people are
not getting promoted and maybe I need
less office space and that waterfall
effect has had that there are larger
companies are needing less space and
less demand for leases and so now the
commercial real estate market is
suffering with less demand and we can
thank this crash coming in the sector of
the economy to covid and lockdowns that
triggered this whole work from home
debate
it's it's interesting you're saying that
because when you look at numbers with
commercial real estate it says
commercial real estate cries still
looming over the US economy and it's not
going away the US economy faces looming
threat of a commercial real estate
market crash at one and a half trillion
dollars on Commercial Mortgage Debt is
due by the end of 2025 tighter credit
conditions higher borrowing costs and
declining property values due to remote
work have increased the risk of default
Fitch ratings estimate that 35 percent
of pooled Securities commercial
mortgages due to April due between April
and December of 2023 total link ready
5.8 billion will not be able to be
refinanced office and Retail property
valuations could potentially drop as
much as 40 percent this year let me say
that one more time office and Retail
property valuations valuations
could drop as much as 40 percent this
year time that means a 10 million dollar
property is 6 million bucks that's
correct
according to Lisa Chalet CIO of Morgan
Stanley wealth management it's not like
it's a regular person saying this these
are people who know and what's that last
bullet say small and Regional Banks
holding about 80 percent of commercial
real estate market outstanding that are
the main source of credit the industry
up people could lead to more restrictive
Landing standards making it harder for
businesses and households to obtain
loans yeah and by the way this is why
and I'll say this openly I'm long on
JPMorgan stock because if those small
Regional Banks going to JP Morgan small
Regional Banks fail who's got the best
credit rating and the best Capital
structures to them for the pick it up JP
Morgan so you're saying buy stock now is
that what you're saying I'm in I'm just
said okay I said it openly so I could be
disclosed I'm long JP Morgan but the
reason I'm long JP Morgan is I believe
they're about to take advantage of the
additional losses that are going to
happen in small Regional Banks who are
holding the credit because who does the
banks in downtown L.A Glendale Federal
and other people like that it's the
local economy that have those big
commercial dollars who does Suarez go to
help the economy you know down in Miami
with big about Bank lending SunTrust you
know that's who he goes to these are
local Partners building up local cities
and they're about to get you know a
local local shots in the shops yeah
we've already I mean when you say JP
Morgan you're talking about JPM Morgan
Chase who's the CEO of that Jamie
Diamond the right he's been on the wall
how many Regional Banks has he already
gobbled up right how many how much money
has moved to the big Banks but Pat let
me touch on that first story capitalized
to do it exactly yeah he's got the money
he's basically what it is it's so funny
here this first story the half the
world's biggest companies are downsizing
Office Space
I've never heard this this term before
unquote office first what does that
remind you of a little bit America first
office first there's a metaphor here
it's it's almost like you talked about
this on the on the uh Andrew Schultz
podcast shout out to Andrew Schultz by
the way in his room his Squad great
podcast but you take you said what's
wrong with being a nationalist you know
nationalist gets a bad name obviously we
know some certain then when you hear
nationalism funny mustache guy yeah
there's a funny mustache guy but what's
wrong with loving your country what's
wrong with loving America what's the
opposite of nationalist you said
globalist and we're seeing the cloud
shops of the world the world economic
Forum here there's a story line here
office first get your ass in the office
work right versus globalism work from
anywhere work from home don't come into
the office don't have any contact with
people you're working with what are we
talking about here there's no borders
why borders there's a metaphor here
right but I think it's important to see
here that 55 of companies are actually
going to increase their office space
what we're realizing is you need to be
adaptable you need to be flexible and
there is a happy medium here some people
they can I mean how many people that
work for PHP don't work in the home
office right they work all across the
country but they do have satellite
offices Regional Offices I think that
the the where we're at today the sign of
the times being adaptable and flexible
is what works for you what works for
your company a company knows all right
10 to 20 we're going to downsize here
maybe they don't need to be here 55 no
your ass is going to be in the office
here there is a story line here
nationalist globalists work from
anywhere office first at the end of the
day the the there is it's a very nuanced
discussion here it's not black and white
Zoom everything with technology people
can work from anywhere but at the end of
the day culture you know what does it
say culture eats what for breakfast
culture each strategy for breakfast if
we didn't work from here to this podcast
together every single day uh I I doubt
we would have the same impact let me
just transition that into what what a
perfect transition on what you just said
I don't think there's a better story for
us to go to than page 21 if you want to
go to page 21. watch this this is where
contradiction and hypocrisy uh uh is
exposed so this is the new Surgeon
General advisory raises alarm about
devastating impact
of the epidemic of loneliness and
isolation in the United States this is
an article from the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services Surgeon
General Dr Vivek Murthy can you pull him
up and see how long he's been a Surgeon
General has issued an advisory
addressing the crisis of loneliness and
isolation the United States which
affects approximately half of American
adults the consequences include a 29
risk of heart disease
a 32 percent increased risk of stroke a
50 increased risk risk of developing
dementia in older adults and a doubled
risk of depression amongst those who
frequently feel alone Dr Murthy proposes
a national strategy to advance social
connection highlighting the need to to
prioritize social connection as critical
public health issue alongside tobacco
obesity and substance use disorders the
strategy aims to mobilize the health
sector reform digital environments
deepen research on social disconnection
and cultivate a culture of connection by
strengthening social infrastructure
implementing pro-connection policies and
promoting meaningful social connections
the strategy aims to build a healthier
more so resilient nation and addresses
the impact of loneliness on diseases
such as heart disease stroke dementia
and depression okay how long has this
guy been the Surgeon General can you go
to it how long has he been in so he's
the 19th and 21st Surgeon General so his
first stint was 2014 to 2017 and then he
came back in office in 2021. so 2014 to
2017 which means Barack Obama the only
reason it says Trump is because Trump
fired him replace them with somebody and
then he came back and four years later
under Obama under Biden which we know
where he leans politically okay by the
way this was the same guy that was
supportive of the shutdown
this is the same guy that said hey
essential non-essential so the level of
arrogance to think how short-term
thinking Americans are that they forgot
what this guy stood for you read this
article if I didn't tell you who was
written by you would say man the guy
that said this what a freaking noble guy
yeah you understand what what are they
what a guy that cares about so many
people for him to say the consequences
of you know loneliness and isolation in
the United States 29 increase in risk of
heart disease 32 increase in stroke 50
increase in risk of development dementia
really so I wonder if the amount of
people that end up dying from covid
those that actually had covet not the
people that died because of obesity not
the people that died because it was a
common cold but they categorized us as a
covet let's just say I'm talking the net
net net net net net people that died
strictly from covet is what they died
from versus how many end up dying from
stroke heart dementia loneliness
depression I wonder what the long-term
effects of that decision is going to be
versus the short-term effects okay is
there a reason why States like Florida
did so well you know what I would do if
I was the sentences Camp I would take
the story and I would say hey
we did exactly what you're saying to do
three years ago two years ago you're
saying it now but it's too late
people are moving to Florida because we
allow people to live and they're happy
people in Florida are happy this policy
produce miserable people now you want to
write this paper to sound like you're
noble now you want to do this if I'm
Trump or the sentences Camp probably
more the sentences Camp I would be using
this story here to talk about the effect
that's having on people today fully
agree PVD fully agree I mean we've
learned the term social distancing uh
that was the first time we've ever heard
that in our lifetime and this article
talks about cultivate a culture of
cultural connection what's the opposite
of distancing connection it's comical
and you know what there's a certain
segment of the population that needs to
hear this message that needs to
understand this message and that is
young men especially young men under 35
you know Dr Scott Galloway NYU talks
about the most dangerous men in society
are broke lonely men on their phones
sitting at home all day and those people
that situation was exacerbated during
coven okay those people are struggling
like hell right now
social social media apps everything on
dating apps prioritize the top of the
top the the top guys out there they're
doing just fine okay uh you think you
know what do they say Ben Affleck in
Boiler Room uh you think money doesn't
buy happiness look at the smile on my
[__] face if you're doing okay if
you're a top G out there things are fine
but the young guys out there that are
working from home not getting any action
not out there networking they are
struggling and I empathize with these
guys what's the answer though you got to
get out there you got to work out you
got to improve you got to work on
yourself life happens outside of your
phone you have to get out there the
number one thing in life the one thing
I've realized in life it all comes down
to people and relationships and being
able to interact with other people and
and have deep actual connections life
happens outside of your phone you have
to get out there and put the phone down
and genuinely interact with other people
and that's the one thing we learned
during covid and that's the one thing
that was taken away from us social
interaction what do we do in Addison
during covet what do we do we work from
the office every day every day when they
said we're non-essential yeah we worked
at the office every day the only day I
took off was one Sunday 90 days straight
every single flipping day but so many
people fell for this no no no
social distancing no no no they scared
the crap out of so many people yeah that
they fell for this you know you know
what percentage of people fell for the
most those were Bachelor degrees
oh really those are bachelor's degrees
you know who was the lowest those were
the mbas
it's interesting do you remember that
study that came out that was the group
was the highest and then phds and then
high school the high school grads they
were lower to trust the whole social
distancing than the bachelor the
bachelor's degree amen so what we got to
do social distancing you know stay six
six feet away from your book when you
read it because God forbid maybe the
book has covered yeah all these weird
things that they fell for right why do
you think that was pbd because because
sometimes a bachelor's degree is a sign
of you are a person that just goes after
whatever the government tells you to do
and you can't question anything your
program yeah you're programmable yeah
sometimes you got to be like my man no
I'm not doing this you know what what
one of the girls that was at our house
uh from the baseball thing you weren't
there we're doing Dylan's baseball thing
uh celebration
and a father sitting there and I said so
hey I look at his daughter she's got a
Chief's sweater on I said oh so you're a
Kansas City Chiefs fan no
so there was well there's a school here
that I'm a fan of that school Okay cool
so is that the school you go to no I was
going to a different school what school
were you going to well I was going to
XYZ how long have you been going there
for many years why did you leave and she
just looked straight out of that doesn't
want to answer the question and the dad
is a stud total thought of a guy he's
like well you know he's just gonna just
kind of beat around the book I know
what's the reason why I learned
something you're safe here why did you
leave you finally said listen we are so
sick of all this woke agenda at this
school time you know what the school is
the school is the school that you know
it's like well it's constant pride month
you know climate change you know if you
write a paper
opposing lgbtq you could get an F
because you're wrong in the teacher's
eyes let me get this straight
they call and they teach
parents to become conformers I'm at a
baseball hitting practice with Jen and
Dylan and Senna the father has his kid
going to Pinecrest that's playing
baseball there and the father says I had
to call to apologize
because if I don't my son may possibly
not play baseball what the hell do you
mean you have to call to apologize
because it's their way or the highway
and you know what's happening those
types of schools are gradually having an
exodus good slowly but surely you can't
be doing stuff like that parents are
going to rise up and they're going to
say this is pathetic I'm not following
this here anyways let's go to the next
story unless that time you have a final
thoughts if you don't we can go to the
next story no but the return to office
seems to be a hell of a solution for
people that are looking for social
connection pro-connection policies and
to have eyes on you with co-workers to
say
say when him and I were both late that
one day during the Bitcoin conference
everybody goes yeah it's safe to say
yeah the people are back at work again
right now Taylor Made a joke all right
uh okay so let's go to uh let's go to
the next story here with Chris Lake CNN
CEO Chris Licht out after Trump Town
Hall Fallout brutal Atlantic article
this is a CNBC story and then the reason
why he got fired page 12 if you want to
go to it
um
page 12 uh where we at here okay there
we go uh Chris like to stepping down a c
CEO of CNN after just over a year in the
position following a series of setbacks
including the cancellation of the CNN
plus streaming service you put that on
the guy he had only been there for a
year and declining ratings Warner
Brothers Discovery the parent company of
CNN announced the departure stated that
a search would be conducted internally
and externally for new CEO licked exit
was triggered by multiple factors
including a town hall event with former
president Donald Trump that Drew
criticism and resulted in a rating drop
additionally rating dropped at a
record-breaking rating additionally an
unflattering article in the Atlantic
titled inside the Meltdown at CNN it's
contributed to the decision in a memo to
staff Warner Brothers Discovery CEO
David zaslav took responsibility for the
outcome and expressed appreciation for
Lick's effort and dedication and here's
a story from political the real reason
behind Chrysler getting fired Chris
slick departure at cnnco was influenced
by critical profile following the
Atlantic again same story lick was
perceived as subservient to Warner
Brothers Discovery sealed David Savvy
made the changes that were seen as
rebukes by CNN staff that his distance
from Newsome newsrooms and failure to
charm their staff worsen his situation
firing licked will not solve CNN's
problem as the cable news industry is in
Decline the new CEO will inherit a
damaged organization and should learn
from Luke's mistakes while building
relationships with the staff Tom Licht
inherited a damaged organization
Malik do you have the the chart we have
on the ratings it's the from The
Economist the pink chart Quicksilver
it was uh send it to you today anyway so
the ratings disaster at CNN had started
um as soon as soon as the election was
over and as soon as that election was
over
um suddenly all they had was coveted
coveted coveted covet number one Chris
Lake gets brought in by David zazlov to
be a turnaround specialist he was a
showrunner this guy is a gifted
showrunner by the way he still is a
gifted showrunner who had a very very
tough year at his job you know he he
built Stephen Colbert show he built CBS
This Morning he built Morning Joe so
this is a showrunner not a guy that's
ready to run an organization and pbd do
we see people like this at the Vault
conference people at the Vault
conference who are running great
organizations versus people who are just
kind of Monolithic Executives Chris
slick is a showrunner hired by David
zazlev to turn turn around CNN take a
look at this what happened to ratings
Pat here's the chart right after the
election whamo they all drop look at
that rating drop when there's nothing to
talk about Trump except January 6 and
it's Covey coveted coveted covet Fox was
the only one that moderated programming
and you can see their ratings dropped
after the election cycle but then
leveled out closer to where they were
beforehand
whereas CNN and NBC Pat you see they're
ready at the same exact level look at
CNN and fox same exact Peak do you see
it first week of November 2020. goodness
the election so that's the mistake
that's right that was mistake so Zazzle
doesn't bring in a turnaround guy he
brings in Chris slick and now and Chris
slick by the way what had happened at
CNN you know CNN had the controversy of
what was that guy sucker uh no the
president the zooming Jacker uh Jeffrey
tuben Jefferson
remember that guy yeah they brought him
back yeah and then um and then Cuomo
they had this issue with uh Cuomo and
then they had Don Lemon was already in
the Penalty Box when Chris Licht walked
in say hey Chris turn this thing around
and so he does CBS this morning and they
said what am I going to do I've got this
ID idea to put women on and do this just
like I did CBS This Morning I'll call it
CNN this morning well you need to use
Don Lemon why well he's under contract
why that was a decision that he got
forced into we all know what happened
there eventually lemon didn't get along
with his estrogen charged um you know
co-host and you look at what happened
here and they were already have it so
was it a good idea that let the Atlantic
follow you around for an article no was
it a oh by the way CNN plus was also
canceled as he was walking in the door
so for everybody that says this was all
on Chris Licht a guy who wasn't a
turnaround specialist was brought in not
a good idea to do the Atlantic thing and
the couple things that he tried to build
the shows he was kind of hamstrung that
didn't work and guess what came out this
morning a story is that the people that
have been talking to the media and
leaking thing is a bunch of Zucker
loyalists who are now back where they
were but guess what the other side of it
is private Equity people know David
Playbook and you know what CNN is only
five percent of Warner Brothers
Discovery five percent
but it was 71 percent of the headlines
for the last six months
that's not what you want no it has I
think zazlov is going to say for what am
I bid for this wounded puppy
I think that's where it's going but I
think they've been too hard on Chris
Licht even though he did there's some
things he did okay Atlantic article not
a good idea by the way just just so
people know who this guy was he was the
executive producer and the showrunner
for The Late Show with Stephen Colbert a
breakout show against other bigger shops
right and and as well as cbs's Executive
Vice President of special programming
he's also known for having launched
Morning Joe on MSNBC and the reboot of
CBS This Morning this is not a guy
that's not like a you know a lightweight
guy he's a he he's part of the
democratic he's part of that Community
he is a guy that's you know willing to
support that Community this guy was a
qualified guy for that job but they
needed somebody to uh Target and go
after another blaming him but he walked
into the Jeff Zucker mess and and you
guys are talking about CNN Chris Lake uh
quote all this starts with one guy all
this demise one guy saying two words to
Jim Acosta fake news this all started
from that one moment and it's gone all
downhill from Trump to where the fake
news comment and then think about it
they put him on the town hall they try
to gain like they want to get some clout
back and then the viewers are like why
the hell did you put them on there it
all started with Trump and I'm so happy
that this is happening to everybody at
that that crappy ass News Network by the
way you said Jim Acosta did you do they
know about when you were in Ukraine no
did they not know that do you have that
clip Rob oh my goodness
you paid visit to Ukraine like four
weeks yeah before we hear see that uh
excellent video that you did while you
were uh right on the grounds of Ukraine
which definitely wasn't nothing happened
no nothing happened to me either the guy
Chris licked number one I don't think
most people can pick him out of a lineup
if you paid them so uh he was there uh
he came in what a year ago he took the
place of Jeff Zucker Jeff Zucker was
running CNN for multiple decades I
actually had a high hopes for this guy
because I think if his campaign message
was anything it was he wanted to bring
CNN more to the middle was that not what
it was yep that was kind of what he was
looking to do and I actually thought
that would have been a good move for
them but what we realized is you need to
play to your base and CNN's base at this
point is definitely on the left Fox News
is based definitely on the right how
many people were up in arms when Tucker
was left let go from from Fox News not a
good look for them but further proof
that cable news is dying and that
they're just looking for anything to
basically as an excuse the ratings were
up when Trump was there and uh you know
when they did the town hall they had
Pence just there
nobody really cared about that but the
interesting thing will be two things
what's next for this guy where's he
going because he's going to be high in
demand I guarantee you that and then
who's next for CNN be very interesting
and people are all up in arms on Linda
yakarino being brought in as the Twitter
CEO let's see who the new CEO of CNN is
and see what they say firing Chris lick
the only person you can bring in
is somebody that Zucker approves of Don
Lemon no no way gotta be somebody that
Zucker approves of and you'll find
somebody Zucker is going to send the
Loyalists but that doesn't mean the
ratings are going to improve to say your
best show was when you had Trump back on
you know how embarrassing that is to the
brand of CNN that's what they're
embarrassed of and lick was just trying
to do his job go ahead Rob play this
clip when Vinnie was in Ukraine working
for CMM a couple weeks ago who was I
yeah go ahead watch this here we're
gonna go live with our in the field News
correspondent glad you made it thank you
on the ground in Ukraine directly In
Harm's Way look how dangerous I'm
looking out there front lines
it's insane Russian forces has
infiltrated
look at the explosion there's gases
left and right and this weather is
but none of that matters the only thing
that matters is reporting Real News Real
News
if I don't make it out of here somebody
please tell my wife oh my God Jim Jim
who's this guy yeah I love you you're so
convincing man thank you you know how
many times I've fallen for your stuff I
appreciate thank you can I get a picture
with you I mean yeah I'm in the middle
of shooting guys I'm freaking believable
this is ridiculous oh my God yeah oh bro
you guys got to keep it up you are so
convincing keep lying for it ratings
it's phenomenal I appreciate it
stop smoking
by the way subscribe to valuetainment
Comedy yeah if you want to see more
stuff like that Vinnie's doing that
thank you thank you CMM centralized made
up media baby anyways okay so let's go
to the next story next story we can go
to is with Tucker Carlson Tucker
Carlson's first episode of Tucker on
Twitter Nets it says 70 million but
that's June 7th I think it's at 110
million right now if not higher Tucker
is on fire
to uh say the least he's absolutely
crushing it with where he's at
the first episode uh okay tour the CEO
Elon Musk acknowledged his High View
count but clarified that it only counts
for views on the X Twitter app or web
browser excluding views from other
sources like Google search results or
Bloomberg terminals Carlson chose Torah
as a platform for his show after leaving
Fox News citing the platform's
commitment to free speech he expresses
hope that Twitter would provide a
platform with without Gatekeepers
emphasizing his gratitude for the
opportunity to be on the platform but
very quickly by the way second episode
came out yesterday which has got
somewhere around 40 million views
and then immediately after his first
episode FOX News tells Tucker Carlson he
violated his contract with new Twitter
show this is NBC News uh Fox News
informed Tucker Carlson is a lawyer that
he violated his contract with the
network by releasing the first episode
of his new show on Twitter the breach of
contracts stated in a letter from Fox
News General counselor Brandon Googer
who referred to Carlson's contract
signed in November of 2019 and amended
in February of 2021 Carlson's lawyer
Brian Friedman argued that any legal
action taken by Fox News would infringe
on Carlson's First Amendment rights
Carlson's new show on Twitter titled
episode one featured his unfounded claim
that Ukraine was responsible for an
attack on a dam in Russia Russian
occupied territory leading to
devastating floods Ukrainian president
zielinski and U.S officials have accused
Russia of the attack while Russia denies
any involvement I mean that's pretty and
and yesterday he's out there doing what
he's doing yesterday if you watch what
he said yesterday Twitter a lot of
people on Twitter are going back and
forth saying what what is this guy
saying is he trying to say something
because a part of what he said in in
episode number two I think 90 seconds
into it or two minutes into it he says
by 2008 no one questioned that Barack
Obama had a highly creepy personal life
what what what creepy what a highly
creepy personal life is he talking about
like Tom what do you think about what's
going on here right now with Fox News uh
suing uh Tucker or getting after him I
love this so let's go to one sentence
that everyone will understand said Fox
sends a letter that said Mr Carlson
Services shall be completely exclusive
to Fox that was under a contract with
fox fox pays Carlson specifically to be
there
now then he goes on Twitter Twitter's an
open platform
and he put a video up on Twitter showing
what he thinks that's it does he have a
contract with Twitter No Elon Musk has
said so there's no contract with this
guy is my fake Elon Musk went out of his
way to put a tweet out remember that
said there is no contract with Tucker
Carlson so he went out and did that this
would be
this is going to be tough for the fox
lawyer to get a judge to injunct and say
oh yeah well you've got a contract with
Fox your servicers are exclusive of the
fox and now you're providing Services
he's going to have to Fox has got to
successfully argue that he's providing
services to Twitter he's not he's a free
guy stating what he believes and put a
video up on a open social media platform
I I don't think fox has an angle here
because what judge is going to say that
is he monetizing his content on Twitter
that's exactly right what's the contract
or do you get casual monetization for
cumulative views does he I I don't know
I mean does that work that's a good
question if he doesn't then there's no
commercial relationship even just a
casual commercial relationship where you
click the button saying yeah send me a
check if there's enough views and you
can sell ads against it but that still
isn't a contract to provide services I I
think he's in the clear I think he knows
he's in the clear and I think that this
is the only angle that fox can take but
they got to find a judge that will
injunct and say this yeah it musk made
it clear that he's not paying him he
says I also want to be clear that we
have not signed a deal of any kind
whatsoever Tucker is subject to the same
rules and rewards of all content
creators rewards means subscriptions and
advertising Revenue share coming soon
which is a function of how many people
subscribe and the advertising views
associated with the content I hope that
many others particularly from the left
also choose to be content creators on
this platform things like the test run
patent guess what he'll do this bro
think about how brilliant this is for
one year he's going to do this and get
numbers at him like 75 million 75 80
million 100 million once Fox lets them
go then they're going to say okay now
it's time to start paying this dude he's
gonna get he's confusing the entire
cable news lineup combined combined
exactly so that's a great move bro get
your name up there and then absolutely
crushing it killing it bro the guy has a
very necessary voice clearly the market
wants to hear what he has to say yeah I
I personally think that he's
the Top If not one of the top opinion
personalities out there I don't consider
him a little journalist meaning
he'll say he's admitted sometimes I'll
say things that aren't right and wrong
and he's not looking to get fact checked
these days but when it comes to his
opinion people do what here want to hear
what he has I love that you said Adam
it's opinion do you know the girl the
executive she's a producer uh Caroline
that was on the flight with her new
girlfriend she's gorgeous no she's
married with kids but anyway we'll get
into that later uh
shut up never listen we had a
conversation where we were saying it's
like your opinion right Tom we are not
even allowed to have an opinion about
what's going on everything that we talk
about is infactual I'm not getting fact
Checker I'm not saying Hey listen this
is a fact I have an opinion he has an
opinion like the north stream pipeline
right like in my opinion why would one
side do it it's pretty much going to be
the other side and that's my opinion I
think they have to try to shut your ass
up if you have an opinion that goes
against their narrative so that's what
thanks for your opinion Ben you're
welcome free
unedited on adult rated let's talk about
the job market real quick behind rise in
unemployment job market is really strong
this is a Wall Street Journal story uh
and there's two stories back to back
I'll read both of them here for you on
what's going on with the job market so
uh unemployment rate increased to 3.7
from 3.4 percent in May but the numbers
of job search indicating a strong job
market the the household survey which
determines the unemployment rate showed
a decline in in employment but when
adjusted to payroll definition household
employment actually increased by 394 000
wages remain firm with a slight
deceleration in overall wages in May but
wages for non-management employees Rose
by half a percent over the past three
months both overall wages and
non-management earnings continue to grow
at rate that showed no sign of
deceleration which may unsettle the
Federal Reserve Health Care government
and you know what that means right that
means interest rates about to increase
Healthcare government professional
sectors added the most jobs while the
information sector experienced a decline
possibly due to a rider strike and then
this leads to the next story U.S job
openings Rose in April reversing
three-month decline
your job openings Rose in April
reversing three-month job decline
indicating strong employer demand
despite a gradual uh slowing economy the
labor department reported a seasonally
adjusted 10.1 million jobs in April up
from 9.7 million jobs layoffs decreased
to 1.6 million in April further
highlighting a solid labor market while
job openings have declined from the
record high of 12 million in May in
March of 2022
uh they still outnumbered the 5.7
million actively seeking in April
various sectors experience changes in
job openings with increases seen in
retail warehouses Healthcare and
transportation while declines were
observed in factories real estate firms
and state local governments the number
of workers quitting their jobs held
steady indicating confidence in finding
new employment opportunities Tom so
there's a couple things going on here
and uh hey Rob can you find look up this
type Fred initial
claims initial job claims Fred and
you'll get this blue chart right here
Fred not the fed Fred interesting that's
a new one
there you go so what's going on here is
two things that we need to there we go
St Louis that's it let's take a look at
this watch for the blue line there's
another
another chart in there but what we've
got here is initial job claims have
suddenly spiked I don't mean a little
Tom can I see them go ahead keep saying
it um and just look at the blue line on
the far left yeah and what happens to
that blue line
um and that came out that came out
yesterday so the initial job claims come
out what does an initial job claim
that's someone after six weeks says I've
been unable to find work I need
unemployment assistance and I get it
from the state so you go to the
unemployment office so those claims are
way up the other one is Rob let's just
go to show the tweet that I had from
Danielle
and what was very interesting going on
here take a look at this there is
the labor department made a birth death
adjustment whoops or we we got this
wrong on birth death they changed it and
look what they did to their own chart
Pat whack
their chart takes this whack and
Danielle and others came out and said
this is Daniel demartino Booth who's an
expert on fed statistics if you look at
the past 12 months 37 percent of the
jobs were made by a birth death
adjustment in other words they weren't
make so when they say that job creation
was up 37 of those is a data correction
and it is a pure estimate from our
government what's not an estimate from
our government is that jobless claims
just spiked last week as people are
looking for real checks so if there's
real jobs out there and the job growth
is up then why are so many people
looking for checks this is the conflict
that's in our Labor Statistics we've had
people recently that were here on pbd
podcast who said
how is it that the government 14 months
in a row kept beating the labor stats
remember that Pat it's because they make
an announcement they go in the
background they quietly adjust it and
then next week they say oh we beat our
estimate so there's a lot of BS going on
and all I I got to say is look at the
number of people laid off look at what's
going in the housing market look at the
number of initial jobless claims I don't
care about the job creation stats when I
look around my community and I can see
people that are in line for unemployment
checks and I see what's going on
um this is the government specifically
Biden Administration is creating good
news out of statistics and there's a
couple times that they've done some
magic spreadsheet work look at that
Spike Pat that was an adjustment that
they made in birth debts the dirt's
going this way no no sorry it's up here
and and you've got experts on this like
Danielle will come out and say 37 of
those jobs are made by a spreadsheet
thank you for that uh breakdown no I
genuinely that's a little more the value
can I add a little attainment to this
thing this other article here I think is
is very entertaining here let me just
read it real quick it's basically
um
it's an article from The Insider it says
no job no problem for some they call
here's a new term fun employment summer
after quitting sounds like a perfect job
fun employment is a term for embracing
joblessness as liberating and empowering
prioritizing personal Pursuits and
self-reflection it's about enjoying life
rather than rushing into a new job the
pandemic has shifted perspectives on
work and life leading to burnout and
restlessness around 28 of laid off
workers plan to take a break before
their next job recognizing the
opportunity of self-care and exploration
those with savings and Severance are
taking advantage of fun employment
summer
they pursue passions personal growth and
even make career changes realizing that
traditional work may not bring them
fulfillment people want to have that
work-life balance people want to have
that fun for employment summer you know
last year was hot girls summer then
before that I think it was white boy
songs shout out to shed Hanks now it's
fun employment summer who needs money we
can get money from the government baby
exactly and let's go back and if you can
you take us back to your man on the
street interview with a young woman that
came from New York with that government
money to have a fun employment week
There's a beginning in the middle to end
of this fun employment the beginning is
you gotta check from the government for
six thousand dollars what are you gonna
do with that money I'm going on spring
break vacation I said oh they were only
giving out 1800 bucks how'd you get six
grand or so she goes I got dependents
maybe oh you got kids I go by the way
how much did you spend on this vacation
six thousand dollars uh how much money
you have left in the account after this
trip I have no money left okay sounds
like that fun employment's gonna be
coming to an end and you're gonna have
what is called unemployment at that
point then you're gonna need to be
collecting unemployment checks and then
you need to be back on the government
situation again and she wasn't
unemployment leads to no money after a
while she's looking for someone to take
her to dinner and you were a cute guy
with a microphone and Vinnie exactly
that's what happens when these girls
collect them fun employment checks they
all they want they want some dude out
there to start funding their lifestyle
gentlemen be very careful of these
leeches out here I need that clip in my
email so I can forward it you know what
and this is an hour times this is a
perfect transition into why vasectomies
this is a True Story by the way the
economist comes out with the story
talking about following the Supreme
Court decision of Dobbs versus Jackson
Women's Health Organization ruling which
allowed states to ban abortion and
demand the vasectomy surge in the summer
of 2022 Dr Doug Stein a urologist saw
registrations for vasectomies almost
tripled the week after the ruling
insurance claims data indicates 17
increase in procedures and a six-month
following the ruling after a with a 29
increase between July and September
while the number of vasectomies have
been gradually increasing in recent
years the rate of Americans who uh have
un undergone the procedure is lower than
it was 20 years ago men who were
motivated by Dobbs ruling cited various
reasons for choosing vasectomy including
concerns about limited access to
abortion as a backup contraception
method Fierce that vasectomy could be
outlawed next and a sense of solidarity
with women vasectomy is being is seen as
a sacrifice that eases the burden of
contraception responsibility from women
and is often associated with gender
quality equality what a noble cause so
when are you guys getting yours done
yeah I don't have any Adam you're trying
to have a kid I I'm trying to have one
so I'm gonna wait I'm impregnating
everybody out there yeah my brother
that's four my brother any thoughts on
this crazy of course of course well this
is going to be a very controversial
controversial take okay it's a brace for
impact
only men can have vasectomies that's
what yeah yeah only men women cannot
have your second phobic transphobia hey
it is what it is you're a phobic just
like only women can have babies I said
it I don't know what no yeah no no no
I'm taking that stance right you know I
actually had a conversation we had a
whole debate about this Rolo uh Rolo
tomasi shout out to him he made a whole
uh shitstorm tweet storm out there
basically saying the quickest path to
being a high value man was to do the
following seven things and number three
I believe was get a vasectomy and it was
very controversial people were like what
are you talking about why would you man
get a vasectomy and basically he says
you know there was a whole checklist of
things
and essentially the what and he
highlighted the quickest path is not
rushing to have kids not rushing to have
a family focusing on yourself focusing
on not having kids focus on your money
focusing on all that which I can
appreciate because I've sort of followed
that path and now that I've made my
money have my network things are good
Life's good I'm fully prepared fully
ready to uh basically utilize my
non-vasectomy to the ladies out there
taking applications and I think I think
that the the next situation is yeah I
would like to have a family and and I
fully agree with kind of what he's
saying and I wouldn't take what he was
saying too literally I don't think
people are rushing to genuinely get
vasectomies but not having kids and not
starting a family at least in your 20s
and even in your 30 30s early 30s I
think is important and then the next
phase I think it is very important to be
a family man well as you know Patrick he
told us you're you're leaving this
weekend so is there any possibility you
want to tell everybody where you're
going and maybe you might pull the
trigger you might come back I'm going
back to Romania to see tape we're gonna
go have great time we did the filming
now I'm invited back and there's a lot
of uh great opportunity great success
so we'll see
yeah but Tom you waited until you're
quiet played this clipboard doctor so
watch this video I love it I love this
slip younger boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge box men do not
menstruate only women men straight now
you can call yourself whatever you want
but trans men do menstrual non-binary
people only women operating is not
exclusive yes it is women no it's not
yes it is
if your chromosomes are xx and you're
young you menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non-violence
Are there women dressed as men you are
not a man camo you pretend to be a man
that's okay that's perfectly fine live
your life tell me what a man is well
what's a man to you you define a man for
me you have chromosomes that are X and Y
that's what a man is so why are we just
looking at the the the the science of
this as a design when words
is what you're born with the sexual
reproductive organisms
I don't accept that distinction you have
to argue for it you're just giving a
conclusion you're you're just making it
up people the people
the truth
if you want to identify in any way you
can you're free to do so but that does
not mean that the rest of us have to
join that illusion you disagree I
disagree with you and so you call it
hate but there's no hate in my heart at
all so that's you are being hateful when
you tell somebody that identifies as a
man that they're not a man
aren't you be honest I tell you I love
that he's wearing a pink shirt I love it
but I got I'm a fifth grade teacher he's
playing with his chest he's like you
know what you don't you don't got a
vagina you know what's amazing you're a
guy I'm a fifth grade teacher come on I
love him bro my new hero number one you
know at the end that he was going to be
called hate and right wing extreme it's
like he's like I'm fifth grade teacher
here buddy why is his voice so important
because this guy deals with
nine-year-olds and ten-year-olds who
think their unicorns and princesses and
Peter Pan and astronauts and they're
living in Fantasyland and they are not
so he knows how to identify people who
are just living in Never Never Land and
being like uh I know Scotty that you
think you're an astronaut and you're
wearing that little or you think you're
a T-Rex you're just a boy so I'm gonna
allow you to think you are you're just a
boy same thing as the [__] out there
you're just a man dressing up in skirts
yeah and and at the end of the day do
you I I hope you get the right because
you know the agenda this for you it's
meant whatever they need to do do and
that's what and that's a great point
that he made I disagree doesn't mean I
hate and like we say listen like leave
the kids let the kids make up their own
decision leave them alone you're
transphobic labels put on you and you
hate them it's like bro do your thing
that's the definition of transphobic is
the hatred of trans people nobody hates
Trend people no saying hey I don't think
you're an actual woman I think you still
got your dick yeah uh and I don't think
you have a period I don't hate you I'm
just kind of telling you the truth the
facts the facts don't give a [__] about
your feelings exactly they really don't
you know Bill Maher what was that four
or five months ago did a beautiful
diatribe and um he just kind of laid it
out and at the very end of it he said me
personally when I was young I wanted to
be a pirate and I'm so glad my parents
didn't send me out for eye removal
[Laughter]
that was how he summed it up exactly he
said it's a phase and everything is a
phase in kids and I think in all
seriously made a great point I I fully
agree I think in all seriousness the
number one thing is you got you guys
want to dress up and do your little
thing stay away from the kids stay away
from my freaking kids oh here's what
with Prager amazing even better
is that the clip or no no no no
where he was like yeah where he goes
through this you want to give a hot take
on this no I don't have a hot take it's
Common Sense man it's just you know you
can keep trying to push this down
people's throat but guess what you're
starting to look like clowns is what
you're starting to look like absolute
clowns and who looks even bigger of a
clown you know who who's the guy that
works at uh what is the guy's name who
works at MSNBC he does the elections man
I wish
no no no give me the names he's like
what is it with these guys that do you
know what studies show that you know the
whole thing about there's only two
different Sexes that's actually not true
do you know recent Studies have shown
I'm listening to this because I'm like
do you realize like you're a pretty
credible guy to say I'll find it I'll
give it to you guys Chuck Todd Chuck
Todd said something
but Chuck Todd did say something along
the lines no no it's chucked out it's
chucked out that's it it's Meet the
Press Chuck Todd chuck chuck University
of Miami
[Music]
it's not just about like you it's like
things have changed and there's
different and the guy was like no no I
don't know yeah it was vivec this was it
pat right yeah yeah that would be big
but but don't do the whole one one
minute and 51 seconds see if you can
find a shorter version of it are you
confident okay I found it I'm gonna text
it to you I'm gonna text it too I lost
all respect for him you gotta hear this
this is like how can you even say
something like that and have still have
credibility uh I texted it to you Adam
You're Gonna Lose respect oh you're
gonna lose it Rob let me know if you got
it it's it's mind-bogging did you lose
respect for him be honest I I don't know
if I had it in the first place to lose
it like there needs to be some respect
to lose it yeah when you when you
continuously say stuff that makes zero
sense you just lose credibility that's
also as simple as that watch this I
can't believe this would be back in
Rebecca's sitting there saying like you
work for this company how did you get a
job for this company watch this go ahead
oh
I love it are you confident that you
know that gender uh is uh as binary as
you're describing it are you confident
it isn't a spectrum
well there's there's two X chromosomes
if you're a woman an X and A Y that
means scientific research there's a lot
of scientific research out there that
says gender is a spectrum Chuck I
respectfully disagree gender dysphoria
for most of our history all the way
through the DSM-5 has been characterized
as a mental health disorder and I don't
think it's compassionate to affirm that
I think that's cruelty when a kid is
crying out for help what they're asking
for is you gotta ask the question of
what else is going wrong at home what
else is going wrong at school let's be
compassionate and get to the heart of
that rather than playing this game as
though we're actually changing our
medical understanding for the last time
I go back to this the lack that a Chuck
Todd what says that there's people that
watched this who are regular people and
say well I'm never going to have a show
on TV especially at a company like that
that guy probably knows what he's
talking about but there's more than two
genders no yeah that week where is The
credibility for something like that what
would make him say that but real talk to
what make what makes him say that he's
reading off his notes and his chart why
would you even say that it's a clown
show because to keep his job he's a
wind-up toy soldier for the left looks
just to kind of so so all of this kind
of ties all together with a company we
are all deeply concerned about and I
think we need to they're you know the
way they're going right now their
funeral is coming soon but uh Bud Light
let's talk about light here Bud Light
experience another week of sales decline
dropping 24 from a year ago
uh this is a fox business story Bud
Light experience another week of decline
last week of May with a 23.9 decrease in
sales on a dollar basis compared to the
same period last year and sales have
fallen another 24 and a half percent the
past four weeks according to Nielsen IQ
Data the sales decline can be attributed
to the backlash faced by Bud Light and
parent company
Anheuser-Busch since creating custom
cans for its transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney in early April however
the week ending May 27 marked a smaller
decrease compared to the previous week
factors contributing to the smaller
decline include effective communication
by enhancer Bush Distributors continued
merchandise placement by retailers and
Strong Memorial Day sales driven by
discounts and rebates and challenging
comparisons to 2022 sales Tom
this is really funny I don't need to
talk about this anymore I mean this is
this is some Budweiser walking with a
permanent limp the way they've shot
themselves in the foot well but what is
happening on the back end for beer
drinkers at one good beer Pat check this
out well once a year you have the Great
American Beer Festival and that's in
Denver Colorado it's known as the Oscars
Brewing
um and it's uh run by you know
independent mines and Sam Adams has
always been a great uh supporter of it
as a matter of fact back in 2009 I
finished third place American pale ale
competition shout out to you in the
business I'm not joking Biz Doc is a
craft Brewer on the side plenty has
space and time which is hard with the
stock babe and two girls in school but
what is happening right now is the craft
Brewers used to make Rich tasty beers
you go into a bar or something like yeah
and it's oh you know the Oregon honey
beer it's got a rich different taste
what they've been making over the course
of the last two years is more
um fast drinkable and mass drinkable
they've been aiming at Budweiser
ironically and there are these five
breweries that have come out of nowhere
and they're being covered on social
media by their followers there's things
going on so what is happening is the
American entrepreneur
uh and craft Brewers are fighting back
and you've got people like the Odell
Brewing Company in Colorado Creature
Comforts in Athens Georgia exhibit a
brewing company which I think is
hysterical and Framingham Massachusetts
dovetail Brewery They are all Brewing
better than Budweisers it's mainstream
American pilsners aim to be better than
Budweisers and they're taking off
because they've gotten lift over the
past month because people are saying why
drink Budweiser why don't you drink the
dovetail Brewery Budweiser copy but it's
actually better than Budweiser and so
American Beer Drinkers are supporting
small entrepreneurs craft Brewers that
are Brewing stuff up so it's not just
the boycott the consumer the Beer
Drinker didn't stop being a Beer Drinker
for the summer they're looking for
Alternatives and are finding it and
they're finding it coming from American
entrepreneurs coming out of the Great
American Beer Festival and I think this
is a fantastic unintended consequence
coming at budwe Tom who who just ranked
up to number one as the most popular
beer in the United States in terms of
mass produced mass-produced
mass-produced Factory beers Modelo let's
go baby one number one
modelo's number one there's problems do
you guys like Modelo I only could drink
it with like like a michelada or
something I only drink it when I'm
pissed off but I'll Pat you guys see
what Dylan Mulvaney said about this
whole thing he said uh more companies
should work with more diverse groups of
trans people after this whole debacle
would Bud Light and he said and I quote
for a long time I felt so lucky that
these opportunities were coming my way
that I thought it was by accident but
now I realize how much power I actually
have he goes if a brand wants to work
with me so bad then they should work
with other trans people too it's not
enough just to hire me this white skinny
trans girl I want all the dolls to be
getting brand new like all these brand
deals go ahead so if you're listening
you're a company start hiring a bunch of
these a bunch of these guys and see what
happens to your company it better not be
a masculine freaking but like numbers
numbers don't lie don't face
don't favor them no it doesn't and it's
in beer it's not just a boycott we are
now shifting away from giant woke
Factory beer companies and independent
entrepreneurs and little Islands in this
company a country are winning and I
think is fantastic yeah so to wrap it up
here guys before we finish up the
podcast there's a story that came up
about Mel Gibson I kind of want to talk
about this the story was about I even
retweeted it it's a story about the
child trafficking documentary that he's
doing a four-part documentary it was
written by Newsweek saying that he's
doing this so uh uh is this the Newsweek
one yeah is Mel Gibson making okay
reports uh having merged claiming that
Mel Gibson is working on a four-part
document series I'm covering the global
child sex trafficking Market involving
countries like Ukraine social media
influencers Matt Wallace tweeted it's
time to expose the truth while the
founder of the operation undergrounded
railroad Tim Ballard hinted at Gibson's
involvement in the doctor series
Gibson's represented denied a rumors
stating they are inaccurate however high
profile political influencers have
expressed support uh with the former
Arizona governor nominee Kerry Lake
stating Mel Gibson's heart and soul are
in the right place Gibson's
controversial paths including racist
anti-semitic and sexist comments as fuel
speculation however fact Checkers have
revealed that certain quotes attributed
to Gibson are false and misleading so we
don't know what's going to happen
whether he's going to produce it or not
if he does he would be the right guy to
do it and this Tim Ballard guy has been
involved in this for quite he had some
trouble I think also a couple years ago
but it would be very I'm reading this
book by Tommy mottola yesterday about
the story of timing I couldn't put the
book down and
you know there's a part where he was
trying to make a movie and this movie
was supposed to be him and uh Robert De
Niro and some big name guys that we're
gonna do this okay and last minute
they're sitting there saying it's it's a
story about going up against pedophilia
and what was really taking place and
last minute it never got funded for the
movie to be made so movies like this
documentaries like this shows like this
there's a lot of people that want don't
want to do it because where are you
going to platform it where you're going
to put it up but if there's a guy that
could do it and pull it off it's
definitely Mel Gibson I put it on
Twitter I put it on Twitter yeah that's
why what's gonna happen yep and I think
musk would be okay with that anyways
again we covered a bunch of different
stories today once again for those of
you guys that are staying wanting the
Tate interview text award
310-340-1132 text the word Tate to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 there will be no podcast
next week go ahead yeah well I just want
to give a quick shout out to everybody
that showed up to the live event event
that we did last week the fresh and fit
podcast we sold out shout out to the
valutina crew out there that came that
was amazing thank you for the
opportunity pbd I hope we didn't let you
down it was awesome shout out to the
team and thank you again for the Tate
trip it was awesome amazing you were
low-key the MVP of that trip you're
hilarious you got a lot more we had an
awesome trip interviews like yes coming
up here and very soon yeah and we're
both out next week you're going to be
with your family and you're gonna be
back in Romania I'm going to be out next
week but uh okay sounds good take care
everybody we'll see you guys soon
bye-bye